yeah strong then hey i [ __ ] myself
i didn't i didn't but i did but you you
you you had a full week of [ __ ]
yourself
this is last week i'm still [ __ ]
myself yeah so
after the podcast we went to uh izakaya
which we'll talk more about later yeah
yeah uh
and uh we had liver and
well you and only me and meline had
liver
and meleen didn't tell me i was like is
anyone else sick and melee was like nope
nope
later she was like oh yeah i was sick by
the way i still want to think that you i
gave you covert or something
and i'm like what the [ __ ] tell me
you're sick we're way to go milan thanks
a lot
thanks thank you so much thank you for
endangering your hosts
so i'm pretty sure it was like that that
that got me like food poisoning got me a
few poisons
because god and i didn't have the liver
yeah yeah i remember you messaging us
being like hey is there is anyone
feeling tired and joey said he's feeling
fine i was like
yeah i'm like feeling pretty fatigued
you know maybe maybe we've just done a
lot
didn't realize like conor was just dying
in in the next room
so like the day after i remember i had a
call at like 10 a.m and i was fine and
then i got a bunch of jojo merch shipped
cool yeah
great i opened it day in life of connor
jojo merch came in very normal day for
me and then
after i like opened it put it down i was
like [ __ ] holy [ __ ] i'm tired like
i'm weak
i was like oh my god and then later on
in the day i was like i'll order a curry
you know
i don't know that's a good idea i have
no idea why i thought a curry was like
the best idea
and i ordered like a lot and i also ate
a lot of it like i had a whole non
like [ __ ] tons of rice real [ __ ]
spicy curry
yeah sides as well like i went for some
reason i went all out because i was like
what my body needs
is energy right that's what it needs and
the best way to get energy
curry dirty dirty curry and then i was
like
okay i feel a little better like in the
first five minutes yeah
immediately after i was like oh no i'm
i'm in like pain
like my stomach started really really
hurting yeah i was like [ __ ]
[ __ ] and then this whole time i'm
thinking do i have covered like do i
have code
yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] i mean that's that's
the first thing that goes over anyone's
mind right
now who gets ill yeah right now like i
sometimes i have like a slight fever i'm
like [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] i'm dead it's coming you're
going there i caught a cough in public
i'm dead dude everyone's going to think
i've covered no but i was like
especially
with you because you texted me being
like bro like i almost [ __ ] fainted
yeah yes so like the that night uh i
texted you that the next day yeah and
uh the night of i was like curled up in
a ball in my bed boiling but like
shivering
yeah sweating non-stop my bed was like
damp as [ __ ] when i woke up it was
disgusting i know i'm sorry
and and then i had like a horrible
horrible fever couldn't get out of bed
i had such bad stomach pain at night and
i was like all right i gotta vomit i
gotta go
yeah yeah and then i vomited and i was
like great i feel good
and then i sleep for one hour and then i
vomit again yeah yeah and then i've got
i'm [ __ ] myself all day
i'm dying i can't get off the floor i
like nearly fainted and then
like like an hour later i fainted and i
was like oh my god all right i gotta go
hospital because
this is like covered right yeah yeah so
there's like a hospital right next to
our house which is lucky uh it's like a
five minute walk yeah yeah yeah and i
had a friend call them up and see if
they like could let me in yeah and
they're like yeah sure come on down
and so they were like yeah come through
the back come on come on down oh they're
like yeah man just bring that insurance
bring that and bring that big old
insurance card come on down
and then uh i went there and they were
like
someone like oh fu or something was
going to greet me
and someone comes out like a [ __ ]
hazmat suit yeah
like i was like yeah yeah
and they bring me in they lock me in
this room alone because obviously they
think i might have coving
symptoms yeah and then uh they're like
uh
nihongo daisy and i was like
and then they are like oh okay okay so
then this they bring a nurse in who can
speak like pretty broken english
and luckily there's one doctor in this
building that could speak like
semi-decent english yeah
so he came in he was like you have
covered symptoms so
we give you tests and i was like oh cool
cool cool yeah sure
and then he's like he's like i will put
this in your nose and i'm like okay
and then she [ __ ] grabs my head like
this right like
from a dummy from a [ __ ] distance
grabs my head and shoves this thing
and i'm like ah because it's like it's
quite long
yeah yeah yeah it's like it's like this
big yeah yeah it's [ __ ] horrible
and he puts it in and then he puts it in
a little bit and i'm like okay this is
fine then he's like
you know how like when they put the
sword in the stomach you put a little
bit and
it in yeah i'm pretty sure that's how
like they used to give labor yeah
that's all the things they push it and
they start like the eyes drooling away
yeah yeah yeah he was like doing that
and then he [ __ ] shoved it in and i
was like ah
i was like and then like the nurse was
like laughing at me
bear in mind i in this whole time i have
no idea what's really happening they say
i'm gonna do a bunch of other tests and
stuff and i feel like a lab rat
i'm just like in this room i don't know
what's happening and they're like sure
okay and then immediately after that i'm
like
oh it's time isn't it
they're like laughing because obviously
like i have like very selective words
that i can choose from yeah i don't know
the actual words yeah i'm like trying to
like pick
the closest words to describe what's
happening it's like how many
times how many ways can i use the word
and then and then she's like and then
she's immediately after right where i'm
like this right she grabs my arm
starts putting the like blood thing
around me oh yeah
yeah and i literally was like because
i'm like still like i'm like faint
because i'm like i'm already feeling
like
like feverish i'm fainting i'm gonna
faint like please you just shove this
thing in my mouth like i'm dying like i
literally said like
and then she again she's giggling and
i'm like what the [ __ ]
i'm just like stick sitted and i'm like
okay okay i got no saying this and then
she's doing it and i'm like all right
nemo memory cause i don't know how to
say i'm gonna faint but then she takes
it out and she's like props you on the
bed and i'm like all right
she's just like sanju and i'm like okay
cool cool yeah for the covered results
yeah yeah
and then she comes in the room and she
looks at it turns around and she's like
looking really happy she's like ah sugoi
it's uh
bad though
no joke she says bad and i'm like she's
like
you got it it's bad you did it and i'm
like i'm like it's bad
i'm like negative positive she's like oh
oh negative i'm like
you're [ __ ] kidding me you're kidding
me don't scare me like that that is the
most like beautiful like google
translated conversation i've ever seen
i'm sitting there the whole 30 minutes
thinking all right five kobe i gotta
tell like joey i gotta tell i've
gone i've gotta tell everyone i've been
in contact with yeah i've gotta tell
them everywhere i've been
gotta stay at home for two weeks like
i'm like [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] like everything
yeah and then she said that to me like
[ __ ] look
it's bad and then luckily it was nothing
and then they did like more tests to me
it was really fast though it was like
two hours i didn't have to wait or
anything yeah
as some from the uk it's really weird
going to any other health
uh healthcare system and just being able
to get your results and
going seeing the doctor the same day
having an x-ray on the day of and
getting the results on the day that
doesn't happen in the uk
i remember i like i thought i broke my
leg and they made me make an appointment
for like a week and a half
to get the x-ray and i thought what bro
my leg is like
[ __ ] now i need the x right now what
do you expect me to do with this for a
week and a half